Der Rasenfunk Kurzpass. Zwei Spieltage sind es nur noch in der 2. Männer-Bundesliga und es ist schon wieder so einiges passiert. Wir blicken auf die Liga heute mal einmal mit dem oberen Segment und einmal mit dem unteren Segment. Hallo und herzlich Willkommen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Hier ist der Rasenfunk Kurzpass Nummer 265 und wir werden heute sprechen über die 2. Männer-Bundesliga. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost, ich bin der Ed Genetzer auf mastodon.social und ich freue mich sehr, zwei Gäste hier zu haben. Zum einen Nando Silva vom HSV-Podcast Volkspark Geflüster, einer der Podcasts, die sich in der großen Podcast HSV-Schwemme damals gegründet haben, der aber immer noch sendet. Das muss man wirklich sagen. Das war wirklich verrückt. Da gab es so eine Zeit, da musste ich bei jedem Update der Podcastshow einen neuen HSV-Podcast eintragen.
Das stimmt, aber wir sind immer noch da. Wir sind auch mit drin und wir sind noch da.
Ihr seid noch da. Irgendwann werde ich mal wieder einen netten Supporter dazu verdammen, mir die inaktiven rauszusuchen und die fliegenden wieder alle aus der Liste. Aber ihr werdet auf jeden Fall bleiben. Schön, dass du hier bist und schön, dass wir in einem positiven Umfeld über den HSV sprechen. Freue ich mich drauf.
Ja, positiver als gedacht und das freut mich natürlich auch, dass ich positiv über den HSV sprechen kann.
Ja, so soll das sein. Und dann werden wir auch über Jan Regensburg sprechen. Das Wort positiv umschiffe ich an der Stelle, denn ich weiß nicht genau, wie es wird. Ich bin aber sehr positiv gestimmt, dass wir hier Max Aichinger haben. Er ist Gründer von der JanBlog.de. Er ist auch treuer Rasenfunk-Hörer. Und wenn ihr im Forum oder im Discord-Channel vom Rasenfunk unterwegs seid, dann kennt ihr den lieben Max auch schon. Deswegen, Max, es ist überfällig, dass ich dich hier begrüße. Und du bist der jüngste Rasenfunk-Gast der bisherigen Rasenfunk-Geschichte. Schön, dass du hier bist. Ja, freut mich auch. Ich hoffe, die Leute werden mit den Maxen nicht durcheinander kommen. Aber ich glaube, das kriegen sie hin. Also, bevor wir loslegen, noch einen Hinweis. Der Rasenfunk ist werbepayable und sponsorenfrei. Wir finanzieren uns ausschließlich über eure freiwillige Unterstützung. Rasenfunk.de slash-Supporters-Club. Da erfahrt ihr, wie das geht, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Jetzt aber wollen wir mal so ein bisschen allgemein auf die Liga blicken, was so in den letzten zwei Wochen passiert ist. Nando, wenn ich dich jetzt einfach auf der Straße treffe und sage, zweite Liga, was ging da zuletzt so? Was wären für dich die wichtigen Themen?
Es gibt auch andere Mannschaften als den HSV, denen ein bisschen die Düse geht im Endspurt und deswegen ist der HSV noch im Aufstiegsrennen dabei. Das wäre, glaube ich, das Erste, was ich in Hamburg sagen würde, wenn mich jemand fragen würde. Es ist halt erstaunlich, dass Darmstadt jetzt zwei Mal in Folge verloren hat. Das hätte niemand erwartet, so stabil, wie diese Mannschaft die ganze Saison gespielt hat. Die schien nicht zu erschüttern. Und dann verlieren sie zu Hause gegen St. Pauli. Und dann verlieren sie in Hannover. Und sehr schön, dass Paderborn ganz seriös weiter spielt und Heidenheim schlägt. Und damit macht es da vorne die drei noch mal ein bisschen kuscheliger, als es noch vor zwei Wochen aussah.
Ja, könnte vielleicht so ganz leicht von deiner HSV-Liebe geprägt sein, dieses Kompliment an Paderborn. Aber ja, es ist schön, dass sie nicht abschenken, während ja gleichzeitig andere Teams wie St. Pauli und Düsseldorf durch das, dass sie gegeneinander unentschieden gespielt haben. Das hat keinem von beiden so richtig geholfen. Die sind jetzt deshalb ein bisschen weiter weg. Max, was gibt es sonst noch so, was in der Liga los war?
Ja, ich glaube, ich würde sagen, dass der spannendste Absteckskampf in Deutschland, glaube ich, auch hier weitergeht. Für uns nicht, auch für andere. Pillefeld und Nürnberg immer noch. Zwei große Traditionsverrennen im Absteckskampf. Dann mit Rostock in der Mannschaft, die sich irgendwie in den letzten Wochen rausgerettet hat. Keiner weiß so richtig wie, aber irgendwie haben sie es geschafft.
Na ja, mit vier Siegen halt. Zwei Punkte, das hilft wirklich einfach. Also Rostock jetzt mit 37 Punkten im Grunde so gut wie raus. Vier Punkte Vorsprung.
Ja, und ja, Bielefeld und Nürnberg irgendwie, da dachte man lange Zeit, sie werden sich irgendwie raus retten. Und jetzt zwei Spiele vor Schluss stehen sie auf 15 und 16. Und ich glaube, es wird spannend und brenzliche Wochen für die beiden Farine.
Ja, absolut. Also Nürnberg, da haben wir ja im letzten Kurzpass schon mit Vardekir Blaby darüber gesprochen, der ja schon den Klassenerhalt mal ausgerufen hatte. Werder Bremenfans wissen, das sollte man nie tun, denn dann kann das schiefgehen. Immerhin wusste die Arminia die ganze Zeit, was auf sie zukommt, nämlich Klassenerhaltskampf. Klassenkampf wollte ich schon sagen. Das folgt dann wahrscheinlich erst, wenn man abgestiegen ist, sollte man denn absteigen. Also die beiden hängen richtig unten drin. Um jetzt kurz den Hörern und Hörern die Tabelle nicht so wie wir vor Augen haben, das Bild zu zeichnen. Einmal kurz der Blick nach oben, einmal kurz der Blick nach unten und dann sprechen wir auch über eure Vereine. Also Darmstadt, 64 Punkte. Damit hat man 10 Punkte Vorsprung auf den ersten Nicht-Religationsplatz. Das ist also schon safe, aber man hat es eben verpasst durch diese zwei Niederlagen, den Aufstieg schon fix zu machen. Drei Punkte Vorsprung hat man auf den FC Heidenheim. Der Theorie nach könnte das jetzt dann also am nächsten Spieltag safe sein. Und Heidenheim durch das Unentschieden und die Niederlage in den besten beiden Spielen ebenfalls verpasst, alles sicher zu machen. Ganz im Gegenteil. Heidenheim, 61 Punkte, damit nur ein Punkt Vorsprung vor dem HSV mit 60 Punkten, der jetzt wieder die Möglichkeit hat, die Relegation zu vermeiden. Alles dahinter ist dann eher theoretische Diskussion, denn Paterborns, St. Pauli und Fortuna Düsseldorf haben 6 Punkte Rückstand. Das heißt, da müsste dann schon der HSV beide Spiele verlieren plus noch alle anderen Spiele gewonnen werden plus die Tordifferenz noch mitspielen, dass sich da noch was dreht. Das ist relativ unwahrscheinlich, würde ich sagen. Auch Nando traut sich da nicht pessimistisch zu sein, obwohl HSV-Fans gut darin sind, pessimistisch zu sein. Oder?
Nee, also Platz 3, glaube ich, schenken wir nicht mehr her. Der ist sicher und das dürfte auch ein bisschen Sicherheit geben, dass man den nicht noch groß irgendwie verteidigen muss bis zur letzten Sekunde. Das denke ich auch. Also die drei oben, das sind sie, die das ausmachen werden.
Das sind sie, die drei oben. Und dann blicken wir jetzt noch mal kurz nach unten. Da ist es nämlich nicht mehr ganz so eindeutig. Also Sannthausen und Regensburg, die haben abreißen lassen in den letzten Wochen. Da sind es jetzt dann schon fünf Punkte Rückstand auf den Relegationsplatz. Wenn wir wissen, dass es noch sechs Punkte zu vergeben sind, dann kann sich da jeder seine eigene Prognose herbeizimmern. Und dann haben wir Bielefeld 33 Punkte, Nürnberg 35 Punkte, Eintracht Braunschweig 36 Punkte. Die liegen also alle innerhalb der Range eines Sieges. Und dann geht es mit Hansa Rostock und Fürth weiter. Das sind dann schon Teams. Da müsste schon quasi mehr als nur eine Niederlage plus die Mannschaft dahinter gewinnen. Also die dürfen sich noch nicht komplett rausrechnen, aber sind es wahrscheinlich de facto dann auch schon. So hat sich die Lage in der 2. Männer-Bundesliga entwickelt. Und dann wollen wir doch mal näher einsteigen, Nando, was beim HSV so los ist. Erstmal jetzt tatsächlich zu diesen letzten Spielen. Du hast gesagt, anderen Teams geht genauso die Düse wie dem HSV. Ist es denn so, dass dem HSV wieder eine Verunsicherung anzumerken ist?
Zumindest war es in der Rückrunde nicht ganz so souverän, wie man sich das erhofft hat. In den letzten Jahren kennt man das. Jetzt vielleicht nicht unter Tim Walther, aber davor, dass man gute Ausgangsposition auf brutalste Weise verspielt hat. Und jetzt in der jetzigen Rückrunde konnte man meinen, dass vielleicht wieder der ein oder andere wackeler. Und da wurden natürlich auch die Diskussionen laut. Liegt es am Spielsystem? Liegt es am Trainer? Oder ist es eine typische HSV-Krankheit? Mittlerweile scheinen sie sich ja wieder gefangen zu haben. Und das, was Darmstadt und Heidenheim machen, ist eigentlich eher typisch für den HSV der letzten Jahre in der 2. Liga gewesen. Am Ende eine komfortable Führung dann aus der Hand zu geben, unnötigerweise. Aber ja, momentan – es ist halt immer schwierig, auch als HSV-Fan dem HSV zu vertrauen. Weil wir haben in der Rückrunde gute Spiele gemacht, gewonnen und darauf folgte dann wieder ein schlechtes. Dann folgte wieder ein toller Fight gegen St. Pauli, wo man denkt, ey, das muss doch Auftritt geben. Dann kriegst du danach wieder auf die Mütze. Jetzt hast du gegen Paderborn nicht schlecht gespielt, 2 zu 2 zu Hause. Das war vernünftig gegen den Nachbarn in der Tabelle, gegen eine offensiv starke Mannschaft. War das absolut in Ordnung. Toll in Regensburg gespielt. Aber was heißt das schon jetzt für Samstag? Das ist immer so ein bisschen das Fragezeichen, was so ein bisschen hängen bleibt bei uns. Da sind wir ein bisschen leidgeplagt in den letzten Jahren.
Und für diejenigen, die nicht wissen, was ist am Samstag, da ist Kräuter wird. Die kommen nach Hamburg. Und dann wird man natürlich in Sandhausen das letzte Spiel bestreiten. Denn das muss ja irgendwie so sein, wenn es um einen möglichen Aufsteiger aus der 2. Liga geht, dass da irgendwie Sandhausen immer eine Rolle spielt. Und beim HSV ja nochmal ganz besonders. Aber wenn du jetzt versuchen müsstest, den Finger drauf zu legen, was da passiert ist in den letzten Wochen. Also das, was ich interessant fand beim HSV, war, man kann natürlich die üblichen Annahmen machen, von wegen im April geht es eben einfach dahin. Und es ist eine Verunsicherung. Und vielleicht ist das auch wirklich so. Man kann da nicht reingucken, was da in diesem Verein und bei den Spielern passiert. Was mich aber vor allem irritiert hat, war, ich hatte das Gefühl, manchmal hat der HSV mit guten Leistungspunkte hergeschenkt, Unentschieden und Niederlagen bekommen. Das ist eher so, also so ein bisschen das Klischee-HSV-Bild der letzten Jahre. Und manchmal fand ich aber, dass man gar nicht so toll gespielt hat und dann aber sehr souverän gewonnen hat. Das gab es meiner Meinung nach in dieser Rückrunde auch schon. Würdest du da erst mal zustimmen?
Absolut, ja. Also genau, es gibt Spiele oder es gab Spiele, da ist der HSV in allen Statistiken unterliegen, Parameter klar überlegen. Man sieht auch optisch, das sieht alles wunderbar aus. Der Ball will nicht rein, man kassiert eins und irgendwie kriegt man das Spiel nicht gedreht. Und es gibt Spiele, da sieht es nicht gut aus, da ist es nicht der Offensiv-Fußball, den man gewohnt ist, den man vielleicht auch erwartet. Aber am Ende stimmt das Ergebnis. Und das macht Fußball auch immer ein bisschen brutal. Am Ende ist es ein Ergebnisssport. Und beim HSV passt es halt in der Rückrunde von den Ergebnissen leider nicht so konstant. Und da wird man sich sicherlich am Ende der Saison auch hinsetzen müssen und darüber sprechen müssen intern. Und wir Fans, wir machen es ja eh immer jede Woche, jeden Tag, dass auf die Vergangenheit geschaut wird, wo hätte man einen Punkt gewinnen müssen oder wo hat man zwei liegen lassen. Es ist halt typisch für den HSV. Ich glaube, das kommt auch bei dir im Süden ganz gut an, wie hier oben die Gemengelage immer auch unter den Fans ist und wie die Diskussion heiß hergeht, weil wir natürlich auch eine große Medienlandschaft haben, die alles sehr dankbar aufnehmen. Sei es kurze Zitate oder Aussagen, die zwei Wochen später dann dafür genommen werden, um die Niederlage irgendwie noch schlimmer zu machen. Die aber nach einem Sieg getroffen wurden in einer guten Ausgangsposition. Es ist kompliziert mit dem HSV in der 2. Liga. Das würde man glaube ich bei StudiVZ oder bei Facebook damals in seinem Beziehungsstatus schreiben. Im fünften Jahr ist es mittlerweile wirklich kompliziert. Denn der Wunsch und der Wille aufzusteigen, der ist, bei der Mannschaft zu spielen, bei den Fans sowieso. Ich meine, die Hütte ist ständig ausverkauft. Auswärts ist es immer ausverkauft im Gästeblog. Also der Support und der Zusammenhalt ist da. Wenn es jetzt noch sportlich einfach mal so flutschen würde, dass man am Ende auch gemeinsam feiern kann, wäre das, glaube ich, schon eine ganz große Sache.
Und dann ist es ja jetzt nicht komplett zufällig, dass ich euch beide ausgerechnet für diese Sendung hier eingeladen habe. Denn der Jan und der HSV haben gegeneinander gespielt an diesem Spieltag. Und ich wusste, das war für mich sehr komfortabel. Egal, was passiert, es ist ein Thema. Hätte der Jan gewonnen, dann hätten wir drüber geredet, Mensch, der HSV, jetzt verspielt es wieder. Das gibt es doch nicht.
Dann wäre ich nicht gekommen.
Und jetzt wurde es aber ein 1 zu 5-Aussicht der Regensburger. Und deswegen muss die erste Frage an Max gehen. Wie war es denn diesmal beim Spiel? Wenn wir drüber sprechen, manchmal hat der HSV gut gespielt und Punkte liegen lassen, manchmal mit einer nicht so guten Leistung sehr überzeugend gewonnen. War das jetzt bei dem Spiel auch so, dass das 5-1 ein bisschen zu hoch war?
Also ich muss vorwegnehmen, ich hatte leider wieder Hoffnung mal wieder nach dem Trainerwechsel. Dazu später mehr wahrscheinlich. Aber man hatte eine gewisse Aufbruchsstimmung bei uns und dann geht das Spiel los, vier Minuten und dann wird man überrannt. Es klingelt einmal nach dem anderen. Und dann, glaube ich, kann man am Ende schon sagen, es ist in der Höhe verdient, es wäre noch mehr gegangen für den HSV, was eigentlich schon für uns traurig ist. Aber ich war eigentlich schon überzeugt vom HSV, aber dann in der zweiten Hälfte habe ich schon gemerkt, dass sie es jetzt eher ruhig runterspielen und nicht mehr so wie in den ersten 20 Minuten ein Vollgas-Fußball-Pur, sondern mehr so ruhig runterspielen. Und dann haben sie das halt auch eingefangen im Fünf-Eins, was völlig verdient ist in der Höhe.
Also es stand schon 3 zu 0 nach 29 Minuten und dann in der 46. Minute, spätestens dann mit dem 4 zu 0 von Sonny Kittel, war der Deckel drauf. War das Walther Ball, der da einfach sehr gut funktioniert hat in Regensburg, Nando?
Ja, ich denke, das war die gesamte Palette von Tim Walters Spielidee. Also je nachdem, wie Regensburg versucht hat, den HSV zu stören, gab es entweder ein überladener Mittelfeld oder eben Diagonalball auf Yata, der mit seinem Gegenspieler machen konnte, was er wollte. Das sind einfach die Tage, wo das Phänomen Bakker-Yata dann zuschlägt. Der dann einfach nicht zu halten ist, egal, was Regensburg gemacht hat. Ich glaube, am Ende hatte er drei Gegenspieler gegen sich. Der erste musste nach 20 Minuten raus. Genau, aber der sah bis dahin auch nicht gut aus. Dann hat Gimba mit versucht zu unterstützen für den eingewechselten Spieler und es hat nicht funktioniert. Und der HSV hat in der ersten Halbzeit das gnadenlos ausgenutzt. Und das ist sicherlich ein Zug im System von Tim Walther, wenn man eine Möglichkeit sieht, wo der Gegner verwundbar ist und es funktioniert, dann reitet man diese Welle auch so lange, bis der Gegner sich drauf eingestellt hat. Und nutzt dann eben die Unordnung, um über die andere Seite zu kommen, wie dann Ludovic Reis plötzlich links durchbricht und nicht Dom P. Um dann die Lücken, die sich anbieten oder angeboten haben, dann auch so zu nutzen. Und wenn dann die Chancen vorne gemacht werden, was ja auch immer mal ein Manko war, auch bei Robert Glatzel, ja dann geht es leider dann leider im Sinne von Max aus Regensburger Sicht, aber für uns natürlich dann glücklicherweise auch mal so aus, wie man es gespielt hat in der ersten Halbzeit. Und ich glaube, das war schon zur Halbzeit mit dem 4 zu 0 schon leistungsgerecht. Also brutal, dass jetzt bei dem sympathischen Max klingen mag, aber ich finde auch, dass in der ersten Halbzeit kann man das nicht kleinreden, das Ergebnis.
Ich glaube, ich habe 25-mal im Jahr aufgeschrieben, dass sie über Dreiecke gespielt haben, jedes Mal, und jedes Mal hat es geklappt. Und dann haben wir es auch einfach nicht hinbekommen mit den Außenverteidigern. Wir standen in jeder Situation zu eng und eigentlich ab Minute 4. Und dann auf der Halbzeit haben wir es dann irgendwie schon langsam hinbekommen, was natürlich auch damit zu tun hat, dass der HSV, wie gesagt, nicht immer so viel Gas geben hat, aber Tim Walther hat wirklich alles in die Hand genommen und uns analysiert und dann uns auch seine Hand genommen hat.
Das ist vielleicht auch ein bisschen die überraschende Quintessenz aus dem Spiel, dass trotz des Trainerwechsels Tim Walther in der Lage war, zu schauen, wie Regensburg auch mit einem neuen Trainer agieren kann. Und das fand ich schon ganz beeindruckend, wobei ich auch ein bisschen Sorge hatte, als Selim Begovic entlassen wird. Und da würde mich interessieren, wie das bei euch angekommen ist, weil das ist ja auch ein Urgestein in Regensburg. Wirklich eine Vereinslegende. Dann wird der so kurz vor Schluss, wo eigentlich schon viel verloren ist, entlassen. Und wir hier oben im Norden haben da gedacht, oh je, ein Trainerwechsel ist wieder typisch für den HSV. Da bauen wir auf. Das Ding kriegt ihr und bei uns ist dann wieder Trübsaal. Von daher, warum jetzt? Also warum drei Spieltage vor Schluss?
Das fragen wir uns alle. Vorweg im Umfeld hat sich die Stimmung nach Sandhausen und nach Ostrog wirklich um 180 Grad gedreht. Die Boer, die vorher immer zum Ersatz gestanden haben, haben sich irgendwie abgemendet, weil die Mannschaft blutleer war. Und das auf allen Ebenen taktisch, mental total am Boden. Also ich glaube, auch im Trainerwechsel, auch im Spiel, ich war in der Mixed-Sonnens. Ich glaube, ich habe drei Spieler bei ihnen gesehen. Also das war echt krass. Und dann, wie es im Umfeld aufgenommen wurde, überraschend, weil jeder hat gedacht, wir gehen jetzt zu Ende mit dem, was er gesagt hat. Ich hätte gern gesehen, dass man am Ende der Saison, egal wie es ausgegangen wäre, einen Cut gemacht hätte, einen Zauberen. Aber so ist es halt, mein Auge, nichts Halbes und nichts Ganzes. Und als Führer musste ich immer fragen, ist der Trainer Teil der Lösung oder Teil des Problems? Und ich frage mich schon, wie kam er dann nach Rostock, dass er Teil des Problems ist, weil es war ja, jeder wusste, welche Probleme mehr so mit der Mannschaft hat. Das ist jetzt nicht erst nach Rostock gekommen. Deswegen ist er schon mit Frauen-Zeichen bestückt.
Ja, aber war das nicht, ich weiß jetzt gerade nicht, welcher Verantwortlicher das war, der nach dem Spiel gesagt hat, naja, das war halt jetzt unsere letzte Patrone. Also das hat sich für mich angehört nach, wir hätten ihn eh entlassen nach der Saison, das wäre sowieso auseinandergegangen. Jetzt dachten wir, vielleicht kriegen wir diesen Trainer-Effekt, vor dem Janando auch Angst hatte. Wir kriegen ihn, okay, ist total nach hinten losgegangen, dann gehen wir halt runter. So hat sich das für mich jetzt angehört.
Ja, das war Hans Rothammer, unser Präsident. Also er ist überraschend sehr vorne dabei bei sportlichen Entscheidungen, was ich persönlich nicht so gern sehe, wenn sich solche Leute dann in ein sportliches Geschäft einmischen, wo sie eigentlich nichts damit zu tun haben, sondern ich glaube, du kannst das auch vom HSV.
Oh ja, hier sind viele Parallel.
Ja, und wir hatten mit Tobi Werner, meinem neuen Sportchef, ja, da ist jetzt auch schon eine Zeit, da habe ich jetzt gesehen, dass er der starke Mann ist und nicht ein Präsident, der wahrscheinlich, er hat gesagt, es ist nicht sicher, dass er bleibt, also er hat gesagt, wenn man ihn nicht braucht, dann geht er. Wieso ist dann er bei der Pressekonferenz? Einen Tag vor der Entlassung gab es einen Bericht in der mittelbayerischen Zeitung, dass Tobi Werner bei einer Niederlage in Kiel, das war März, dass er da Merz hat entlassen hätte und kurz darauf hat Merz hat Werner an Tchenent, so hört man, einen Kontaktverbot zum Anschluss gegeben, also es ist schon sehr wild gewesen und dann Rothammer hat sich lange auf Merz hat seine Seite gestellt und nach Osterk anscheinend, wie gesagt, die letzte Patrone gezogen, was für mich mit diesem Bericht in Verbindung auch noch fragwürdiger wird, weil sie sagen zwar, es gibt keine Verbindung zum Bericht, aber es würde mich nicht überraschen.
Aber um das mal kurz aufzudrösen, also es wäre eben so gewesen, dass Sportdirektor Tobi Werner Selim Bigovic entlassen hätte, wenn man in Kiel verloren hätte. Das kam dann eben nicht. Das hat dann Selim Bigovic erfahren und war darüber – logischerweise wären wir alle nicht very amused, um das mal so zu formulieren. Und dann hat er aber ein Kontaktverbot ausgesprochen, also sprich, dass der Sportdirektor nicht mehr mit den Spielern zu tun hat. Also kommt das aus der Historie, die Selim Bigovic in diesem Verein hat, dass er überhaupt diese Macht hat, so was auszusprechen? Denn eigentlich ist ja das Hierarchie-Gefälle normalerweise so, der Sportdirektor macht die Ansage und der Trainer wird entlassen.
Ja, also ich glaube, Hubert hat es letztes Mal schon gesagt, nach dem Abgang von Christian ist ein Riesenmacht-Darkum entstanden. Und das hat sich dann anscheinend mehr so ein Teil geschnappt. Und ich kann es verstehen, dass er dann etwas notamuest ist. Also ich glaube, das werden wir alle gesagt. Aber dass man dann zu solchen Grillmitteln greift, das ist nicht Jan-like und das gefällt eigentlich keinem Fan. Weil ich meine, er ist eine verreinzelte Genre, aber dann muss ich auch nicht so etwas umgehen können. Und anscheinend hat es nach dem Viertelspiel, wo wir eigentlich die erste Hubsiit gut gespielt haben und dann irgendwie wieder aus der Hand gegeben haben, hat es anscheinend sehr gekracht und mehr so. Was man so hört, hat sich halt auch mit dieser Negativ-Serie etwas persönlich nicht verändert. Aber man merkt halt, dass es mit ihm etwas gemacht hat.
Also da müssen wir dann gleich nochmal ins Detail reingehen. Das ist alles quasi die Vorgeschichte und das Drumherum zu diesem 5 zu 1. Dann wollen wir aber noch mal kurz ein bisschen beim HSV bleiben, denn da hat sich ja jetzt, ich habe es ja schon jetzt mehrfach angedeutet, die Situation auf einmal, die Wolken haben sich aufgerissen, die Sonne scheint wieder über den HSV, der zweite Platz ist möglich. Hat sich denn was verändert bei Hamburg in den letzten Wochen oder sind es nöde gesagt einfach nur die Ergebnisse der Konkurrenz, die jetzt dazu geführt haben, dass wir so viel Positive über den HSV sprechen?
Ich glaube, in Hamburg selbst, also bei der Mannschaft und beim Trainer, hat sich nichts geändert. Da werden die Aussagen eigentlich wiederholt und dabei bleibt man auch. Das mag den einen oder anderen nerven, aber das, was Tim Walther am Anfang gesagt hat, sagt er jetzt immer noch. Da ist das irgendwo authentisch und er hat den kompletten Rückhalt der Mannschaft und er vertraut seiner Mannschaft. Von daher glaube ich, dass sich da intern in der Kabine nichts geändert hat. Die Ergebnisse der Konkurrenz helfen jetzt natürlich, um das Ganze positiver zu sehen. Dass man gegen Regensburg in der zweiten Halbzeit ein paar Körner sparen konnte, weil man nicht mehr das Gaspedal voll durchdrücken musste, wird helfen im Endspurt und vielleicht auch in der Relegation noch ein bisschen Luft zu haben. Ich glaube, dass dieser positive Effekt nicht nur, wenn der HSV verliert, ja, ihr seid zu blöd dafür, sondern dass eben auch andere Mannschaften verlieren, hilft, dass der Mannschaft, auch dass der Glaube, den man selbst hat, dass der auch ein bisschen darin bestärkt wird, auch die anderen rutschen aus. Wir machen einfach unsere Hausaufgaben. Wenn der HSV die nächsten beiden Spiele gewinnt und dritter ist, ja, dann ist das mit 66 Punkten dann einfach mal so. Dann muss man in die Relegation. Und wenn man seine Hausaufgaben gemacht hat und Glück hat, dann steigt man direkt auf. In beiden Fällen, glaube ich, hat sich in der Ausgangslage für den HSV, der eh diesen Druck hat, gewinnen zu müssen, den hat man sich selbst mit dem Saisonziel auferlegt, aber der ist irgendwo auch der Anspruch, ist ja auch berechtigt mit diesem Kader. Den hat man, glaube ich, von vorne rein. Und wenn jetzt die Ergebnisse passen, ist es erstmal in der Stimmungslage ein bisschen positiver, vielleicht hier in Hamburg. Das dreht sich aber, wenn du das nächste Spiel nicht gewinnst. Ich glaube wirklich, dass die Ergebnisse der Konkurrenz dazu führen, dass es vielleicht über die HSV-Grenzen hinaus jetzt auch ein bisschen positiver dargestellt werden kann. Weil natürlich auch für den neutralen Zuschauer oder die Zuschauerin jetzt richtig Spannung reinkommt. Also im Grunde kannst du auf einen Ticker gucken und sagen, oh, was passiert denn da drüben? Oh, jetzt sieht es aber interessant aus. Und das haben wir natürlich alle letzte Woche Sonntag auch gemacht.
Ja, genau, weil da ja auch alle parallel zueinander gespielt haben. Das war richtig geil, so wie es eigentlich sein soll, die ganze Zeit die Blitz-Tabelle aktualisieren. Wer sind denn so die Spieler, die jetzt besonders herausgestochen sind in den letzten Wochen? Also unter anderem gibt es ja eigentlich eine Lücke, die man für musste, jetzt schon länger als nun in den letzten Wochen. Aber mit Mario Vuskovic hat man ja aus den Gründen, die wir alle kennen – vielleicht können wir da auch nochmal kurz drüber sprechen – aber man hat da ja auch sportlich einen herben Rückschlag erlitten.
Das ist sicherlich auch eines der Probleme, die man in einer Winterpause nicht mal eben gelöst bekommt. Also eine Stammabwehr, wo dir vielleicht der talentierteste Innenverteidiger wegbricht oder der vielleicht individuell stärkste, auch wenn Sebastian Schoenlau als Führungsfigur eine andere Gewichtung in der Mannschaft hat. Aber Mario Vuskovic ist mit sicherlich der Innenverteidiger, den man nicht mal eben so ersetzen kann. Das hat man probiert mit einem Transfer, das hat nicht funktioniert. Dann hat man ein jung talentiertes Eigengewächs, der lange nicht gespielt hat und dem man diese mangelnde Spielpraxis angemerkt hat. Das war natürlich ein Faktor, der dazu geführt hat, dass man eben auch defensiv die eine oder andere Schwierigkeit hat, dann mit Verletzungen, Sperren dazu. Und das scheint sich aber jetzt so ein bisschen gefangen zu haben. Jonas David macht aus meiner Sicht in den letzten Wochen einen sehr stabilen Eindruck neben Sebastian Schoenlau. Also da hat sich die Viererkette zumindest in der Innenverteidigung wieder gefunden. Und man schafft es eben individuelle Fehler gut intern wegzustecken, wie eben auch bei Miro Moham, der sicherlich das eine oder andere Gegentor ganz gezielt durch einen blöden Fehler verursacht hat, aber nicht fallen gelassen wird. Deswegen würde ich sagen, dass erstmal die gesamte Mannschaft sehr intakt ist. Also das, glaube ich, merkt man schon an, weil das bei Rückschlägen in den Medien nicht dazu kommt, dass irgendwelche Internas aus der Kabine – und ich stichel gegen den und gegen den – das gibt es beim HSV tatsächlich aktuell nicht. Das haben wir auch schon ganz anders erlebt. Und ein Spieler, der sicherlich in den letzten Wochen dafür gesorgt hat, dass es wieder deutlich besser funktioniert, ist Sonny Kittel. Und das ist einer, dessen Vertrag ausläuft. Der hat in den letzten sieben Spielen sieben Scorer aufgelegt, war eine Zeit lang nicht da, sollte im Winter weg, dann blieb er doch. Jetzt muss er nicht die Last der Verantwortung des großen, talentierten und hervorragenden Fußballers und Führungsspieler tragen, sondern ist in einem funktionierenden Gebilde, wo eine Lücke entsteht, weil Reis viel attackiert wird, der viel Last getragen hat. Bénez ist nicht ganz so schafft, da einzusteigen und plötzlich kommt Sonny Kittel und trifft und legt noch einen vor und trifft erneut und bringt eben ein gefährliches Element in die Offensive, was dazu führt, dass Dom P, Iata, Glatzel mehr Platz haben und der Fokus nicht mehr darauf liegt. Wir schalten Robert Glatzel aus und wenn da mal ein Iata fehlt, oder ein Dom P seine Dribblings nicht gewinnt, dann kommt schon nicht mehr viel. Mittlerweile hat sich das ein bisschen verschoben. Und ich würde schon in den letzten Wochen sagen, Sonny Kittel ist da ein bisschen der X Factor.
Ja, dadurch sind allein, wenn man sich anguckt, wie die Tore fallen, das ist eben nicht mehr einfach nur schnell den Flügel runter oder Flanke auf Glatzel, der sich körperlich durchsetzt. Da gibt es auf einmal Steckpässe aus dem Halbraum und so Funky-Kram. Du lachst, das sieht man nicht mal in der ersten Liga. Ich gucke es ja genug, also das ist schon wirklich erstaunlich und zeigt das Zentrum des Spielfelds. Manche geben es halt schon richtig auf, weil die Gegner heutzutage die Zentren sehr gut verteidigen. Aber es ist immer noch möglich, da zu attackieren. Da kann sogar auch die gute alte Raute vielleicht noch mal irgendwann zurückkommen. Das kann schon Sinn ergeben. Jetzt haben wir ja schon ein bisschen Abstand zu dieser Vuskovitsch-Entscheidung. Also er wurde ja wegen zweier positiver Dopingproben auf Epopositiv verurteilt. Und dann haben wir alle sehr viel gelernt über bildgebende Verfahren und wie überhaupt solche Epoproben durchgeführt werden, wie die NADA und die VADA organisiert ist. Und es gibt unheimlich viele Fragezeichen dazu, ohne dass einer von uns dreien jetzt sagen könnte, Majo Vuskovitsch ist schuldig oder er ist unschuldig. Beides ist gleichzeitig möglich. Das ist er ist quasi Schrödingers Katze. Nur das Problem mit Schrödingers Katze ist zum einen, dass er die Frage war, ob sie stirbt schneller als ein Atom zerfällt. Also das kommt ja noch mit dazu. Eigentlich ist das ein ganz schön krasser Vergleich von Schrödinger gewesen. Aber vor allem diese Katze wurde jetzt nicht ihres Berufs enthoben und quasi aus dieser Mannschaft rausgerissen, ohne dass ich jetzt sagen will, ich weiß es nicht. Wenn er schuldig ist, dann ist das natürlich die gerechte Strafe dafür. Aber wie blickst du denn jetzt mit ein bisschen Abstand auf diese seltsame Nummer – so muss man es glaube ich einfach nennen – in der es immer wieder neue Wendungen gab und man dann irgendwann selbst als gut informierter und in meinem Fall ja Journalist einfach die Waffen strecken musste und sagen musste, okay gut, es ist anscheinend nicht zu lösen und so ganz kann man sich aber auch auf Gerichtsbarkeit nicht verlassen, die ja im Sportgerichtsbarkeitsbereich ja nochmal eine ganz eigene ist.
Ja, also wir wollen da glaube ich nicht zu weit auswohlen dazu, aber es ist für mich ein Stück weit nicht nachvollziehbar, wie die Gerichtsbarkeit, also die DFB Sportgerichtsbarkeit da geurteilt hat. Also grundsätzlich gilt ja im Dopingverfahren ein positiver Dopingtest ist der Beweis der Schuld und der Athlet ist angewiesen seine Unschuld zu beweisen und dann fängt die DFB Sportgerichtsbarkeit an und sagt ja dann müssen wir vielleicht noch eine dritte Probe analysieren von einem unabhängigen Gutachter und dann ist sie doch nicht nötig in der Urteilsbegründung. Das wirft eben genau diese Fragen und Zweifel auf und grundsätzlich habe ich selten erlebt und ich hatte vorher, es gab einen Dopingpodcast mit H. Seppelt glaube ich, der viele dieser bekannten Dopingfälle versucht hat, mal zu erläutern, auch wie er da mit den Sündern gesprochen hat, die ihre Unschuld betreut haben, aber dann doch eingeknickt sind oder wirklich erwischt wurden. Und Mario Vuskovic hat sich sogar geweigert, eine Vergleichssperre anzunehmen, die ihm angeboten wurde. Das spricht schon sehr dafür, dass da wohl vielleicht doch ein Messfehler passiert sein könnte. Man muss ja hier im Konjunktiv sagen, ich würde es mir natürlich wünschen, aber das reine Grundverständnis ist, da gibt es eine Doping-Probe, die ist positiv und das muss zweifelsfrei positiv sein. Und dann muss der Athlet auch gesperrt werden, weil das sind die Bestimmungen. Und wenn hier solche Zweifel entstehen, dann muss man eigentlich einen Athleten zur Not auf Bewährung freisprechen, meiner Ansicht nach, wenn man ihm nicht nachweisen kann, dass das alles sauber gelaufen ist. Also irgendwo müssen auch Verfahrensfehler dem nicht noch zu glastendes Athleten gehen. Da tue ich mich momentan schwer. Also ich bin da wirklich ein bisschen verzweifelt und weiß auch nicht, ob überhaupt beide Parteien sauber aus dieser Sache rauskommen, weil irgendwann entscheidet die höchste Gerichtsbarkeit und sagt, das reicht uns nicht. Aber das bedeutet vielleicht auch im Umkehrschluss nicht, Mario hat es nie getan. Aber der Beweis reicht uns vielleicht. Das ist alles nicht mehr schön. Und so sollte ein Anti-Doping-Prozess und ein Anti-Doping-Verfahren eigentlich nicht funktionieren, weil in der Folge kann es ja auch bei jedem möglichen anderen Athleten genau das gleiche auftreten. Und dann wird das alles ad absurdum geführt und wir wollen alle einen sauberen Sport haben, egal in welchem, nicht unbedingt nur Fußball. Ich meine, beim Radsport-Co, da ist das Problem ja noch um ein Vielfaches größer. Also ich bin da ein bisschen verzweifelt und bin eigentlich eher schockiert, dass das solche langwierigen juristischen Spitzfindigkeiten braucht und das immer noch nicht entschieden ist.
Also ich versuche mal kurz, obwohl ich mich jetzt nicht mal eingelesen habe für die Hörerinnen und Hörer, so ganz grob nachzuzeichnen, worüber wir jetzt indirekt die ganze Zeit gesprochen haben, bitte spring rein, sobald etwas falsch ist. Denn du bist ja noch tiefer drin, sicherlich als ich. Ich habe mir das vor ein paar Wochen alles drauf geschafft. Also Mario Wuskowski wurde des EPO-Dopings überführt oder vermeintlich überführt. Es gab eine positive Probe. Dazu muss man sagen, EPO ist jetzt kein Doping, was man einfach so sich selber in den Armen jagt, sondern das ist blutzuführend. Da muss es eine Organisation geben, zumindest im ganz kleinen Rahmen. Das kann man jetzt nicht alleine machen. Das heißt, das könnte dann, wenn da wirklich, wenn der Befund zu 100 Prozent korrekt wäre, dann ist das auch kein Zufall, denn das hat man nicht einfach so. Gleichzeitig ist EPO ein Stoff, den wir alle in unserem Körper haben und der eben erst, wenn er gewisse Grenzen überschreitet, als unerlaubtes Hilfsmittel gilt, denn er löst sich auch quasi durch, dass es ein körpereigener Stoff ist, löst er sich auch über die Zeit hinweg auf. Und jetzt, und das ist das, was ich auch jetzt erst durch diesen Gerichtsprozess gelernt habe, ist, wie bestimmt man diesen Wert. Ich dachte, das wird schön in die Zitrifuge reingeschmissen und dann werden irgendwelche Körperchen oder irgendwelche Teile werden gezählt. Nein, es gibt ein sogenanntes bildgebendes Verfahren. Also sprich, da hat man dann ein Foto eines Mikroskopen durch ein Mikroskop aufgenommen. Meine Güte, wie kompliziert kann man das ausdrücken. Und dann wird quasi geguckt, was sieht aus wie Epo, und dann wird ein Anteil bestimmt. Und allein am Ausschnitt und an der Art und Weise, wie man das quasi selber interpretiert, visuell tatsächlich, wird dann dieser Anteil errechnet. Und hier beginnt es kompliziert zu werden, denn das ist logischerweise eine ungenauere Methode als eine Messung, die irgendwie quantitativ zu bewerten ist. Und gleichzeitig hängt das natürlich auch dann sehr stark von demjenigen ab, der diese Untersuchung macht. Und da haben wir eben den komischen Nebenfakt, die Merkwürdigkeit, dass die WADA, die Weltdoping-Agentur, und die NADA, die Nationale Anti-Doping-Agentur – also natürlich Anti-Doping-Agentur, nicht Weltdoping-Agentur – dass die darauf bestehen, dass ein gewisser Kreis an Gutachtern, nenne ich es mal, oder ExpertInnen diese Verfahren durchführt und die sich dann auch immer gegenseitig bestätigen, dass sie sauber gearbeitet haben. Und wenn dann jemand wie Moskovitsch kommt und sagt, ich möchte, dass noch eine C-Probe entnommen wird, was nur dann möglich ist, wenn noch genügend Material aus der B- und der A-Probe vorhanden ist, und dass das aber von jemandem anderen gemacht wird, als aus diesem Zirkel kommend, der ja auch ein gewisses Interesse daran hat, sich diese Ergebnisse zu bestätigen. Und wenn das verweigert wird, dann wirkt das zumindest erklärungsbedürftig, ohne dass damit irgendetwas bewiesen wäre. Das ist letztlich die Situation, in der wir jetzt stehen. Plus, es gibt Fälle in der Vergangenheit, wo eben dann im Nachhinein dokumentiert wurde, es war dann doch nicht so, wie es erst aussah. Und wie gesagt, ich will ja auch das Doping-Sünder überführt werden, und ich will jetzt auch keinen Doping-Sünder schützen, aber man muss schon diese Klammern machen im Fall Vuskovic, um es bewerten zu können. Und steht aber trotzdem so ein bisschen betroffen, denn alle Fragen sind offen.
Ja, ich glaube, du hast das ganz hervorragend zusammengefasst, insbesondere eben der Athlet ist in der Nachweispflicht der Unschuld, aber es wird ihm verwehrt, eben diesen unabhängigen Gutachter zu bestellen, damit er überhaupt – das ist ja die einzige Möglichkeit zu beweisen, dass er vielleicht eben doch unschuldig ist, und es wird ihm aktuell verwehrt. So, und dann ist ein Athlet eigentlich machtlos, was er ja vielleicht auch sein muss bei klaren Fällen, aber du hast es eben richtig beschrieben, so klar ist es offensichtlich nicht. Und ja, und so stehen wir jetzt alle da, und ich als vielleicht nicht ganz so objektiver Mensch, weil es eben HSV-Spieler ist, tue mich da natürlich schwer, das alles so zu akzeptieren, wie es gerade läuft, aber am Ende stimme ich zu, wenn jemand gedobt hat, dann muss er gesperrt werden, gar keine Frage.
Ja, und das ist auch einer dieser klassischen Fälle, wo die eigene Meinung ständig hinterfragt werden muss. Also wenn ich Tweets von Jens Weinreich lese, dann gehe ich zu 100 Prozent davon aus, Wuskovic hat gedobt, der soll so lange gesperrt werden wie nur möglich. Wenn ich gewisse wissenschaftliche Artikel lese, im Millanturn ist da auch eine erschienen von Lorenz Adlung, da liest sich das dann eben aus wissenschaftlicher Sicht wieder anders. Und dann lese ich eben Beiträge, die in der SZ erscheinen und so weiter und so fort. Und ständig bekommt man neue Richtungsänderungen in der eigenen Meinung. Und letztlich bewerten muss es ein Gericht. Und es macht es aber extrem schwierig, finde ich, mit diesem Fall umzugehen. Jetzt haben wir das mal so zumindest versucht einzuordnen zu einem abschließenden Urteil. Wird sich sowieso keiner von uns hinreißen lassen. Ich denke, die Fallstricke dieses ganzen Prozesses haben wir jetzt aber mal hier erwähnt. Und reingekommen sind wir in dieses Thema ja mit dem Sportlichen, nämlich, dass das aufgefangen werden konnte. Glaubst du denn, dass dieser Dopingfall, dieser mögliche Dopingfall, auch darüber hinaus noch eine Bedeutung hatte für die Entwicklung, die der HSV genommen hat? Denn es war ja schon vor allem in der Anfangsphase, ich meine, wir alle reagieren auf positive Dopingbefunde. Wahrscheinlich erst mal so, dass wir davon aus genachten, wurde jemand erwischt. Ich hatte schon den Eindruck, es war ein bisschen ein HSV gegen alle anderen Gefühl und das kann ja auch etwas mit so einem Verein machen.
Ich hätte eher gedacht, dass, wenn Mario freigesprochen worden wäre vom Sportgericht, aufgrund eben der fehlenden Sachen, dass das der Mannschaft einen immensen Schub gegeben hätte, positiver Art, und dachte eigentlich eher, dass die erneute Bestätigung, dass Mario ein Doping-Sünder ist, vielleicht eher ein bisschen sich negativ auf die Mannschaft auswirken könnte. Was allerdings passiert ist, ist, dass die Mannschaft weiterhin zu ihm hält. Und ich glaube, ja, das ist ein bisschen vielleicht vergleichbar mit der, also zumindest vielleicht in der emotionalen Stärkung des Mannschaftsgefüges, wie damals mit Bakariata und der Identitätsfrage. Auch da bildete sich eine gewisse Wagenburg-Mentalität um diesen Spieler herum, vor dem man sich gestellt hat und gesagt hat, nein, einfach nein. Hier kommt ihr mit euren Sachen nicht rein. Das lassen wir nicht zu. Und ähnlich stellt sich die Mannschaft im Privaten. Man hat ein Bild gesehen, wo sie alle nach einem Sieg gemeinsam im Restaurant waren und Mario war mit dabei. Und das spricht sicherlich dafür, dass das in der Mannschaft stimmt und dass man vielleicht auch bei einem Torjubel sein Trikot hochhält, auch versucht, ein Stück weit für seinen Mitspieler und seinen Mannschaftskameraat und vielleicht auch Freund Leistung zu bringen. Ja, das kann schon einen kleinen Effekt haben, ein kleines Puzzlestück sein, wenn es darum geht, vielleicht noch die ein, zwei Prozent mehr rauszuholen, auch wenn der nächste Meter schon weh tut. Also denkbar ist es. Und es spricht in Summe aber, glaube ich, für ein sehr funktionierendes und harmonierendes Mannschaftsgefüge, was an einem Strang zieht. Und das ist immer ein wichtiges Fund, wenn es am Ende hart auf hart kommt, in Entscheidungen zu spielen.
Welche Rolle spielt da für dich Tim Walther? Weil er stellt sich ja schon oft vor die Mannschaft, dass ich so was aus der Ferne mitbekomme. Also spielt er da auch eine Rolle, dass das Konstrukt so gefestigt ist?
Ja, ich glaube, dass Tim Walther sogar ursächlich für diese Wagenburg-Mentalität innerhalb der Mannschaft ist. Inwieweit das vielleicht bei dir unten angekommen ist in Regensburg. Der HSV hatte hier große Probleme mit dem ehemaligen Vorstandsvorsitzenden, hatte ein bisschen Probleme mit Aufsichtsratsthematiken und einem Präsidenten, die alle so ein bisschen nicht ganz so einverstanden waren in der letzten Saison mit der Niederlagenserie. Und dann hat sich die Mannschaft einfach zusammengeschlossen und hat fünf Spiele am Stück gewonnen und ist in ihre Legation eingezogen. Und obwohl man dann gegen Berlin zu Hause das 2-0 verliert und nicht aufsteigt, schickt Tim Walther die Mannschaft im ausverkauften Haus auf die Nordtribüne. Die Mannschaft wird gefeiert und dann fangen die Fans an, Tim Walthers Namen zu rufen. Und er hatte hier keinen leichten Start. Aber er hat sich immer vor die Mannschaft gestellt. Er hat nie irgendwelche Spieler, wie man so schön sagt, vor den Bus geworfen. Und die Ableitung daraus, dass er es intern nicht tut, ist, glaube ich, ein bisschen zu kurz gesprungen. Ich glaube schon, dass er intern kritisch ist. Aber er zieht alles auf sich, er kennt die Medienlandschaft sehr gut. Er hat in Stuttgart gearbeitet, da ist es auch nicht anders. Er weiß also, wenn er den Fokus der Medienlandschaft und der Kritik auf sich zieht, kann die Mannschaft in Ruhe arbeiten. Ich glaube, der Trainer tut das für die Mannschaft. Das honoriert ihm die Mannschaft, solange er in der Mannschaft fair und ehrlich ist. Und das tut er, weil da gibt es genug Spieler wie Noah Katterbach, die sagen, ich habe noch nie so schnell einen guten Draht zum Trainer gehabt. Es gibt keine Spieler, die sich öffentlich beschweren. Ich glaube schon, dass Tim Walther, soviel er auch anecken mag, essentiell wichtig ist für die aktuelle Konstellation mit der Mannschaft, dass da so eine geschlossene Einheit ist. Auch wenn natürlich am Ende die Spieler auf dem Platz die Leistung bringen müssen und er auch für die taktische Spielidee mitverantwortlich oder hauptverantwortlich ist. Aber für diese Geschlossenheit glaube ich schon, dieser Typ Tim Walther, der sich nicht zu schade ist, vorne hinzustellen und vielleicht auch medial die Prügel zu kassieren und zwei, drei Wochen später mit irgendwelchen Zitaten konfrontiert zu werden. Ich glaube schon, dass das sehr, sehr wichtig ist, weil so einen extrovertierten, charakterstarken Trainer auf der Bank hatten wir lange nicht. Daran muss man sich auch erst mal gewöhnen, aber er fängt viel ab.
Ist vielleicht auch manchmal der Prallbock. Da stellt sich auch die gute alte Uli Hoeneß-Frage, wie viel ist Strategie und wie viel ist ehrliche Emotionen, wenn er zum Beispiel sagt, ich gucke keine 2. Liga, das interessiert mich nicht, oder wenn er sagt, ach, das ist mir doch völlig egal, wie die spielen, wir steigen ja eh auf.
Ich weiß nicht, ob du dazu noch mal was sagst. Natürlich ist das sicherlich auch ein Stück weit Strategie. Ja, er polarisiert und ich glaube schon, dass das einfach auch manchmal seine Art ist, das auch dann direkt rauszuhauen. Und sicherlich wird das auch ein Stück weit Berechnung sein. Der kennt das Geschäft und Klappern gehört dazu, sagt man ja auch immer. Aber auf der anderen Seite, wenn er dann ganz in Interviews ganz ehrlich antwortet, er war bei Kicker meets the Zone und hat da zu seinem Spielsystem und seiner Taktik und seiner Idee das Gleiche gesagt, was er gesagt hat, als er hier angetreten ist. Also da ist er dann auch authentisch. Da ist er auch ganz gradlinig, da ist er überzeugt von und da hört man auch keine Widersprüche.
Okay, dann jetzt Butter bei die Fische. Also Darmstadt spielt noch gegen Magdeburg und Fürth. Wir haben schon gesagt, bei 4 Punkten Vorsprung auf den HSV. Darmstadt, die Ligien, die werden durchgehen, die steigen auf. Stimmt ihr beide zu? Setze Frage an euch beide. Nando träumt noch. Ich sehe es an seinem Funkeln in den Augen.
Ich versuche gerade irgendwie ganz objektiv – ich kann es nicht. Darmstadt scheint unglaublich nervös zu sein. Da haben sich zwei gelb rote Karten abgeholt im letzten Spiel, die man, wenn man sehr stabil ist und von sich überzeugt ist, so sich nicht kassiert. Also die fängt man sich so nicht ein, insbesondere die zweite nicht. Magdeburg ist unangenehm. Ich glaube, wenn Darmstadt es gegen Magdeburg nicht klarmacht und da sehe ich nicht den Sieg im Vorbeigehen, die können noch Dritter werden. Die haben nämlich das schlechteste Torverhältnis von den drei Mannschaften da. Das könnte unangenehm werden für Darmstadt. Im Normalfall würde ich sagen, die gehen durch, die brauchen im Grunde einen Punkt. Oder was brauchen die zwei Punkte? Nein, sie brauchen einen Sieg, um sicher zu sein. Aber wenn sie gegen Magdeburg nicht gewinnen, dann wäre ich mir nicht sicher. Das ist ein Schlüsselspiel, aber im Normalfall würde ich sagen, Darmstadt geht schon durch.
Und auch hier mega beschissen, ich sage es einfach mal, wie es ist, dass der 33. Spieltag nicht mehr parallel ausgespielt wird. Am Freitag wird dieses Spiel vollzogen. So, und dann haben wir Heidenheim und den HSV. Heidenheim wird zuhause gegen den SV Sandhausen spielen und auswärts bei Jan Regensburg, was die bemerkenswerte Statistik erfüllt, dass sie gegen Rang 18 und Rang 17 spielen. Also der Tabelle nach geht es nicht leichter. Der HSV wird zuhause gegen Fürz spielen, Rang 12. Für die geht es aber wahrscheinlich auch um nichts mehr. Das könnten die am Samstag dann sogar schon wissen. Und dann geht es, ich habe es ja vorhin schon gesagt, nach Sandhausen. Also man teilt sich wenigstens das Spiel gegen den Tabellen 18. Zumindest stand jetzt. Nando, wie geht es aus?
Ja, ich habe, bevor wir aufgenommen haben, Max versprochen, dass wenn Regensburg zuhause gegen Heidenheim gewinnt, gibt es Getränke von mir in die Redaktion von seinem Blog. Das schicke ich gerne was runter. Ich bin mir bei Heidenheim, ich glaube, dass zuhause gegen Sandhausen klingt auf dem Papier ganz einfach. Aber es ist Sandhausens letzte Chance. Also dadurch, dass Bielefeld zuhause gegen Paderborn spielt. Besteht die Chance, dass Paderborn da auch gewinnt. Und dann bleiben sowohl für Regensburg als auch für Sandhausen ja nichts anderes üblich, als ihre drei Punkte zu holen, um irgendwie am letzten Spieltag noch was reißen zu können. Auf dem Papier ist das eine klare Sache. Das gewinnt Heidenheim und dann geht es an den 34. Spieltag. Als HSV-Büch würde ich sagen, Darmstadt unentschieden, Heidenheim unentschieden, wir gewinnen. Und dann haben wir am 34. Spieltag nämlich diese Parallelspiele, die richtig Spaß machen und nicht den Mist am 33.
Ja, aus neutraler Sicht wäre das auch nicht so schlecht. Max, wie ist denn deine Einschätzung? Sollte der Jan abgestiegen sein am 34. Spieltag und dann zu Hause gegen Heidenheim spielen, wird das das letzte große Hurra, indem wir dann sehen, was den Jan eigentlich so stark gemacht hätte, wenn er es auf die Kette bekommen hätte?
Und ich sehe es einfach nicht, dass wir oder Sandhausen Heidenheim schlagen. Ich glaube, der Trainer von Sandhausen hat auch schon gesagt, dass sie eigentlich nur nicht Achtzenter werden wollen. Und Heidenheim hat schon eine enorme Qualität, eine sehr ausgeglichene Mannschaft aktuell. Also, ich bin echt überzeugt von der Mannschaft, vor allem Jan Niklas Beste. Also, wirklich ein genialer Spieler, den wir auch. Und ja, ich sehe es einfach nicht, dass die patzen.
Wir werden es uns angucken. Dann lasst jetzt aber noch mal ein bisschen länger über den Jan sprechen. Wir waren ja schon mal kurz bei der Trainerfrage da. Was ist denn da eigentlich passiert, Max? Also, man lag so wie eigentlich immer irgendwo zwischen Rang 14 und Rang 9. Das war so quasi bis fast zur Halbserie. Hinten raus wurde es noch ein bisschen schlechter. Aber im Grunde, man startet dann in die Rückrunde hinein, in einem Gewässer, in dem man die ganzen Jahre jetzt schon immer war. Natürlich auch den Kontakt nach unten, aber man hatte mit den Abstiegsringen nichts zu tun. Und dann geht es auf einmal runter bis auf den letzten Tabellenplatz. Und bis auf so eine Ausnahme von zwei Siegen eben in Kiel, vorhin schon angesprochen, und dieses 1 zu 0 zu Hause gegen den SC Paderborn. Auch spektakulär, weil unerwartet für neutrale Beobachtende. Aber bis auf diese zwei Siege wird nichts mehr gewonnen, alles wird verloren. Was ist da passiert?
Ja, was ist passiert? Ich glaube, das fragen sich alle aktuell. Wir sind eigentlich alle vor der Winterpause, vor dieser komischen WM-Pause, dachten wir, ja, jetzt geben wir alles in der Winterpause, und dann kommen wir mit einem Siegen raus aus der Pause, und dann geht alles wunderschön. Aber nein, dann verlierst du die direkten Torelle gegen Bielefeld, dann verlierst du Nürnberg wieder ganz bitter, gegen Hannover verlierst du auch. Das sind drei Spiele, wenn du die nicht verlierst, oder zumindest zwei gewinnst, dann schaut die Sache eigentlich ganz anders aus. Aber dann wirkt die Mannschaft ausgelagert nach diesen Spielen, dann wirkt sie mental angeschlagen, und dann kommst du aus diesem Strudel einfach nicht mehr raus. Und dann haben wir wieder Hoffnung aufgeschoben und dachten, ja, Sandhausen und Dross doch, das werden unsere Spiele, das werden die, die holen wir, da holen wir die Siege. Und dann fährt man in Sandhausen im Sonderzug, alles war eigentlich angerichtet. Und wir wussten, wenn wir das gewinnen, dann sind wir wieder voll dabei. Aber nein, die Mannschaft enttäuscht jeder, sie wirkt wieder ausgelagert, und dann verlierst du gegen Sandhausen. Und dann haben wir echt klar, das wird nichts mehr, weil wenn du gegen Sandhausen nicht gewinnst, dann tust du verdient absteigen. Und in Rostock, das letzte Spiel von mir, das war dann auch nur noch eine ausgeraubte Mannschaft. Und taktisch fehlten mir seit Monaten diese Gänenanpassungen, die du einfach brauchst, damit du die Aufmerksamkeit. Des Spiels auch aufhörtst. Wir haben ihm unglaublich viel zu vertrauen. Aber ich glaube, dieser Cut, dieser saubere, der hat uns so in die Gute getan. Ja, der Zeitpunkt, ich bin nicht überzeugt davon, das habe ich aber vorhin schon gesagt. Schauen wir mal.
Da habe ich direkt eine Frage an dich, Max. Weil defensiv stand und steht der Jan Regensburg, wir nehmen jetzt mal den HSV raus. Richtig gut. Also die haben nicht so viele Tore kassiert. Wenn wir das Spiel gegen den HSV mal rausnehmen, da waren nicht mehr als zwei, habt ihr nicht kassiert. Vorne hat es nicht funktioniert. Wurde vielleicht in der Hinrunde ein bisschen die Qualität in der Offensive überschätzt, weil man eben doch aufgrund einer sehr stabilen Defensive den ein oder anderen Punkt mehr geholt hat und sich das jetzt in der Rückrunde recht? Oder weil viel mehr kann der Trainer mit dem Spielermaterial vielleicht auch gar nicht machen, oder?
Ja, ich glaube, wir waren von der Kaderplanung viel zu naiv mit Rückholaktionen und mit Spielern, die einen Namen haben. Wir haben schon irgendeine Richtung. Mit Max Talhamer und Joss Choumès, die waren ein Schlüsselspieler bei uns, die haben uns gezeigt. Mit Dario Fiesinger, Bendy Idrissi, Shitmoski, ein bisschen Spieler, die kannte man aus der 2. Liga und auch international mit Fiesinger und Idrissi. Aber sie funktionieren nicht. Sie passen einfach nicht ins System. Und das wäre eben genau diese Spieler, die offensiv diese Kreativität bringen sollten. Und mit Zabrit Singh, der ist einfach aus dem geplatzen Wechsel im Sommer nach Bremen. Und dann diese Sache mit der Registrierung einfach von der Rolle. Also da ist nichts mehr zu sehen vom letzten Jahr. Das ist ein ganz anderer Spieler. Und da fehlt dann einfach dieser kreative Spieler von der Offensive. Wir hätten mit Urso und Albers eigentlich zwei Stühler, die einfach mal einen reinwachen können. Aber das bringt dir auch nichts, wenn du eben nicht die Bölle nach vorne bekommst. Und wenn wir einfach immer Flanken schlagen, magst du ein Lieblingsthema, wenn du einfach blind Flaken schlägst ohne Plan, dann können wir es gleich bleiben lassen eigentlich. Es ist zu wenig Plan, es ist zu wenig Kreativität und dann hilft dir eine Defensive in dieser Liga auch nichts, weil dann fällt eben mal einer rein. Und dann verlierst du diese Spiele und dann stehst du da, wo du jetzt stehst.
Ja, das ist eben genau der Aspekt, dass diese Niederlagen, von denen du gesprochen hast – Hannover war ja sogar ein 1 zu 1, das war ja nicht mehr eine Niederlage. Aber das war immer 0 zu 1, 0 zu 1, 1 zu 2. Das ist eben das Enge, das abgeschossen werden, das wir jetzt beim HSV in Regensburg gesehen haben. Das ist eben die Ausnahme von der Regel. Jetzt hast du schon ein bisschen über Mesacin Ljubegovic gesprochen und der hat ja auch schon öfter hier eine Rolle gespielt im Rasenfunk. Ich bin mir aber dennoch ziemlich sicher, dass nicht jedem eigentlich klar ist, was er für Regensburg bedeutet. Und du hast es jetzt schon immer mal wieder so kurz durchklingen lassen. Nimm uns doch noch einmal mit auf die große Mesacin Ljubegovic-Reise. Was hat er denn geleistet beim Jahr?
Ja, also Mesac ist in den 2000ern zum Verein als Spieler gestoßen. Ich glaube, aus Bosnien und Herzegowina ist er als Spieler nach Regensburg gekommen. Dann hat er alle auf und abs erlebt. Er war lange verletzt, mal nicht so lange, glaube ich. Und dann hat er eben gesagt, ja, ich bin gegen die Trainerlaufbahn als Co-Trainer der 2. Mannschaft. Und dann ist er einfach immer die kareele Leiter nach oben gestiegen. Dann ist er Assistenztrainer der 1. Mannschaft geworden. Ich glaube, dann als Achim Bayerlutzer, der gesagt hat, ja, er geht jetzt weg aus Regensburg. Und dann hat Mesac die Chance ergriffen und wurde Cheftrainer. Und dann hat er sich eigentlich mit dem Verein der Liga, auch wenn es jetzt eigentlich immer nach unten ging tabillarisch, aber das ist eh nicht unser Anspruch eigentlich, aber rein spielerisch finde ich schon, dass wir uns fortentwickelt haben über diese Jahre. Und auch rein vom Standing her. Das ist im Ehrsatz einer gewesen, der immer da war. Er hat den Verein geprägt. Er war immer da, egal wie es beim Verein lief. Und jetzt ist er eben weg. Und jetzt fehlt ein weiterer Pfeil neben Köln. Und ja, eine ungewisse Zukunft. Und das ist einfach nicht schön, wenn du... Ich bin mit dem WK dann irgendwie auch aufgewachsen. Also, er versteht schon, was ich meine. Und dann sitzt jetzt auf einmal ein Neuer vorne, auch wenn es jetzt übertrieben ist. Aber das ist dann halt schon eine Umstellung. Ich glaube, das geht vielen so.
Ja. Also, Sele Begovic, einfach auf vielen Ebenen eine Identifikationsfigur beim Jan. Und gleichzeitig zusammen mit Keller, der ja jetzt beim 1. FC Köln ist, Christian Keller, hast du auch schon jetzt mehrfach angesprochen, den Namen, Symbol für eine Entwicklung, die stattgefunden hat beim Jan. Also, um die Hörerinnen und Hörer nochmal ins Boot zu holen. Man ist damals 2016, 2017 mit Heiko Herrlich noch aufgestiegen. Dann eben die Achen-Bayer-Lordser-Zeit, die auch sehr erfolgreich war in der 2. Liga, Rang 5 und Rang 8. Das waren die Spielzeiten, wo man im Tabellentipp auf jeden Fall den Jan falsch hatte. Denn das war nicht zu tippen. Es tut mir leid. Weder im einen noch im anderen Jahr. Also zumindest für mich war es nicht zu tippen. Vielleicht bin ich da auch besonders schlecht. Und dann übernimmt eben Selim Begovic. Und wir haben dann eben Rang 12, Rang 14, Rang 15. Also ungefähr das, was ich vorher mit den Fahrtgewässern gesagt habe. Und so ein bisschen schien es aber, als würde der Jan vielleicht das FC Augsburg der 2. Liga werden. Nämlich, die gehen einfach nicht runter, obwohl man als Außenstehender nicht versteht, warum nicht. Und gleichzeitig gab es – und das hat ja hier Robert zum Beispiel, der ja auch schon öfter hier zu Gast war, erzählt – infrastrukturell wirklich so Stück für Stück Verbesserungen beim Jan. Glaubst du denn, auf welchem Niveau steht in deiner Meinung nach der Fußballstandort Regensburg jetzt? Und was würde das denn auch für eine mögliche Drittligasaison bedeuten?
Ja, also ich glaube, rein finanziell und von der Infrastruktur sind wir gefestigt. Also das ist ganz anders als – die Zeit habe ich zwar nicht miterlebt, aber Anfang der 2000er, wo uns mal der Strom abgestellt wurde, also das ist eine ganz andere Welt. Und da hat eben dann, wie ich schon angesprochen habe, Christian Kallar gesagt, also eigentlich müsste man in eine Statue bauen, weil ohne ihn glaube ich, würde es ganz anders ausschehen. Und dann, ich habe ja noch in der Allliga erlebt und das ist einfach ganz was anderes und jetzt bekommen wir dann ein Rezept, also es ist in Planung. Und ich glaube, wenn wir das gebaut haben, dann können wir auch noch einen Schritt mit denen nach oben gehen. Ich meine, die U17 spielt jetzt Bundesliga, die U19 sind da, ich glaube, beiniger ist das oben dabei. Also wir können nicht mehr aufsteigen, aber wir sind oben dabei. Also auch von der Jugend her können wir definitiv uns was erhoffen. Und finanziell haben wir mit Philipp Hausen einen Top an. Also das ist eigentlich nicht 2. Bundesliga, was der macht. Ich glaube, das wäre ja schon Bundesliga. Und ich glaube, rein von dieser Sache her ist der Abstieg jetzt nicht dramatisch. Wir sind gefestigt, es tut nicht weh, aber halt. Ich habe es so oft gesagt, die Art und Weise ist einfach, keine Ahnung, unglaublich bitter und das tut an einem Herzen, wie du siehst. Ja, die hatten es so oft in der Hand. Und dann, ja, jedes Mal wieder gibt es einen auf die Fresse, auf Deutsch gesagt. Aber ich glaube, wir stehen jetzt noch einmal um dir auf die Frage zurückzukommen. Wenn wir so zwischen 2. und 3. Liga pendeln, das wäre, glaube ich, so unser Bereich. Also nächstes Jahr muss auf jeden Fall für die 3. Liga ein stabiles Jahr her. Und bitte nicht Absteckskampf, das halte ich nicht mehr aus. Also bitte einfach stabiles Laufen, Haufen, Weißen, Verträge aus. Also die Gefahr ist da, dass wir unten drinstecken nächstes Jahr. Und eigentlich will ich noch gar nicht von Aufstieg oder irgend so was hören, weil ich glaube, es wird härter als sich viele vorstellen.
Da hat sich die Frage erübrigt, ob das Ziel der Wiederaufstieg ist, glaube ich. Das war so der erste Gedanke, wenn man Max so reden hört, wie gefestigt und wie infrastrukturell alles aufgebaut ist, spricht ja eigentlich vieles dafür, dass man dann mit einer guten Kaderplanung den Wiederaufstieg angreifen könnte. Aber so wie Max spricht, muss ich die Frage wahrscheinlich wieder zurückziehen.
Ich weiß nicht, Max, darf ich sagen, wie alt du bist? Fünfzehn, ist das richtig? Sechzehn. Entschuldigung, du bist inzwischen sechzehn. Aber du sprichst wie ein 50-jähriger Mann, der sagt, ich halte das einfach nicht mehr aus, bitte nicht wieder Abstiegskampf. Also was hat denn der Jan aus dir gemacht? Du bist im Vergleich zu uns, wir sind quasi beieinander. Und mir ist es ein Wahnsinn, dass wir überhaupt noch den Mund aufkriegen, so alt sind wir im Vergleich zu dir. Also da bin ich auch selber ein bisschen persönlich sauer mit dem Jan. Das kann ja nicht sein, dass ihr aus euren jungen Fans so jede Lebensfreude rauszieht. Bitte, was soll denn das?
Ja, also man wurde schon ziemlich erfolgsverwöhnt. Also der Eindruck darf eigentlich gar nicht dastehen, aber ich bin schon ziemlich verbunden mit dem Verein und beschäftigt mich jeden Tag eigentlich mit dem Verein. Und dann tut es einem halt einfach weh, vor allem wenn ich die Spieler danach sehe, wie die damit hadern auch. Und ich glaube, der Jan hat ein sehr enges Umfeld. Und da tut es einfach eben weh, wenn der Verein auch so, wie ich vorhin mit dem Berichten und so angesprochen habe, wieder im Chaos verfällt. Und natürlich ist dann die Angst da, dass es wieder bergab geht. Aber eigentlich, realistisch gesehen, glaube ich, geht es nicht so bergab. Aber wir müssen halt jetzt mal wieder auf den Boden der Tatsachen ankommen. Und das ist einfach die dritte Liga, wo wir eigentlich daheim sein sollten aktuell.
Auf der anderen Seite ist der Max so jung und der Jan hat ihn so geprägt, dass er einen großartigen Blog gegründet hat, der ich mir mit 16 nicht hätte vorstellen können, so über den HSV zu sprechen. Das ist beeindruckend. Auch wenn er ein bisschen von der Emotionalität gerade klingt, wie leidgeplagte Fans nach 40 Jahren. Ist das, was du für deinen Jan machst, mit deinem Blog überragend stark? Mit 16 Jahren habe ich an ganz andere Dinge gedacht und war froh, wenn ich für 2, 50 Mark einen Holsten auf den Weg zum Stadion bekommen habe. Also Hut ab, das ist wirklich alle entwertend. Ich habe mich da ein bisschen eingelesen und beeindruckend. Allein das wäre schon wert, dass Regensburg eine gute Saison nächstes Jahr spielt und vielleicht dann dir auch ein bisschen mehr jugendliche frische Verleid in der Stimme, um ein Max-Bild mit aufzunehmen.
Orientiert euch einfach an der Leistung des Jan-Blogs. Dann klappt das auch auf jeden Fall mit dem Wiederaufstieg. Was ist denn jetzt dein Gefühl gegenüber Tobias Werner, der ja als Geschäftsführersport jetzt an der entscheidenden Stelle sitzt und ja auch in große Fußstapfen tritt? Ihr hattet ja auch die Möglichkeit, mit ihm zu sprechen, glaube ich.
Ich glaube, eine Woche später hat er ihn dann entlassen. Also er oder Utham.
Herzlich willkommen beim Sportjournalismus.
Und ein Bild von ihm, ja, ich weiß nicht recht eigentlich, was ich von ihm halten soll, weil in Jena, was man sich hört, waren sie jetzt am Ende auch nicht mehr so 100% überzeugt. Da denke ich mir, ja, ich habe mit Roger Stülz jemanden, ja, das hat einfach nicht gepasst, einfach hinten und vorne nicht. Das war ein reines Chaos am Ende. Und dann, dass man wieder so einen Unerfahren hat. Da weiß ich halt nicht, ob das so gut für Renes vor allem in dieser Lage ist. Aber er muss sich in der Öffentlichkeit offensiver positionieren. Man hört eigentlich gar nichts von ihm außer halt bei uns Fan-Medien. Aber das ist halt, wie soll ich sagen, für die breite Jahngemeinde halt dann auch zu wenig. Da muss ich eine größere Medien mal positionieren. Man hört nur sehr vereinzete Sachen und halt auch viel zu allgemein. Ich meine, wenn ich die Vertragsverlängerungen höre zum Beispiel, dann heißt es ja, mir bin ich im Rat ein Kapitän im Vertrag vor Ligen. Aber der unterschreibt einfach nicht. Und Christian Kaller hätte jetzt gesagt, ja, entweder du unterschreibst jetzt in drei Wochen oder du kannst schauen, wo du bleibst. Und das macht halt Tobi Werner jetzt. Ich weiß es nicht, aber ich kann es mir vorstellen, weil ich ihm so einen Pikan so nach und ab wahrnehme, wirkt es halt sehr unerfahren. Und das ist nämlich zu verübeln. Er kann auch nichts dafür. Es ist eine riesen Chance für ihn. Er muss lernen, er muss sehr gezahlen. Das hat mir wagt, er nicht. Und ich denke, er kann es definitiv, aber er muss jetzt auch mal zeigen, dass er es kann.
Nicht mal Lehrgeld hat er, Jan. Meine Güte, das sind ja sämtliche Kassen leer. Und gleichzeitig sind ja damals mit Christian Keller auch die Chefscouts zum 1. FC Köln gewechselt. Das kommt ja noch mit dazu. Also, weil bisher ist man ja dadurch aufgefallen, dass man bessere Transfers gemacht hat als mancher Konkurrent und deswegen auch quasi mit geringerem finanziellen Einsatz eben sich in der 2. Liga erhalten konnte. Das ist ein weiterer Aspekt.
Ja, genau, das ist auch unser Punkt. Bisher hört man noch nichts, dass neue Scouts da wären. Das macht mir auch ein bisschen Angst für die kommende Transferphase, mal ich sagen. Ich weiß nicht, ich glaube, mit Robert hat er mal ein längeres Interview geführt. Das ist auch schon 2 Monate her und da hat er gesagt, ja, ihr habt zwar Namen auf der Liste, aber ihr habt noch niemanden gefunden. Das ist jetzt nicht so viel Versprechen für die kommende Saison. Wir müssen gut skaten, wir müssen finden, was sonst niemand findet und das macht schon Sorge, wenn man dann die Scouts nicht hat dafür. Da ist schon ein Qualitätsverlust da, weil wir hatten schon enorm gute Scouts, auch wenn jetzt die letzte Transferphase nicht optimal war. Aber trotzdem fehlt da jetzt ein Puzzletal mehr, was eh schon fehlt mit Köln. Wir müssen schauen, dass wir das in die Tür setzen, auch wenn es schwer wird. Das ist eine nächste Mammutsaufgabe für die Zukunft und wird auch spannend.
Okay, apropos spannend. Dann lasst doch jetzt auch noch das machen, was wir für den Aufstieg gemacht haben, mit dem Abstiegskampf. Lasst doch da jetzt auch nochmal draufblicken und dann sagt ihr uns einfach, wie es läuft. Weil dann ist es ein bisschen weniger spannend für uns, die wir einfach nur so neutral auf die Liga gucken. Also der SV Sandhausen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, gegen wen spielt der? Wenn ihr aufgepasst habt, dann wisst ihr das vielleicht schon. Na ja, ich sage es trotzdem nochmal. Sandhausen spielt auswärts in Heidenheim zu Hause gegen den HSV. Sandhausen hat 5 Punkte Rückstand auf Bielefeld und es ist schon nicht mehr zu schaffen, auf einen Nicht-Abstiegsplatz zu springen. Max, was ist dein Gefühl? Holt der SVS da noch etwas?
Entweder Platz 17 oder Platz 18, was ja auch mit der Lizenz von Hertha bewegend werden könnte. Ich glaube zwar nicht, aber theoretisch wäre das noch mal wichtig.
Ach so, wenn Hertha absteigt und dann keine Lizenz bekäme. Das sind ja Gedankenspiele, die hatte ich noch gar nicht.
Das gab es 2012 und 2013 schon mal mit Duisburg. Da wurde der Jan 18. und dann sind wir natürlich abgestiegen. Typisch Jan eigentlich. Ich befürchte, dass es diesmal auch so wird, aber ich glaube, es ändert sich nichts mehr. Ich glaube, Sandhausen bleibt auf 18 und der Jan leider auf 17.
Das heißt, jetzt dann in Braunschweig und dann am Schluss mit dem großen Holtrio gegen Heidenheim erwartest du keine großen Sprünge mehr?
Ja, wenn ich die Mannschaft so sehe, leider nicht. Ich glaube, jeder will einfach dieses so abschließen. Ich glaube, es geht leider nichts mehr.
Okay, dann wird es jetzt interessant, Nando. Da interessiert mich auch deine Meinung. Bielefeld spielt gegen Paderborn und in Magdeburg, hat 33 Punkte. Der 1. FC Nürnberg spielt gegen Hansa Rostock zu Hause und dann in Paderborn, die haben 35 Punkte. Und Eintracht Braunschweig spielt zu Hause gegen den Jan und dann in Rostock, die haben 36 Punkte. Wahrscheinlich wird es sich zwischen diesen Teams entscheiden, wer dann die Relegation spielt. Nando, was erwartest du?
Das sind harte Fights. Rostock hat es ja so ein bisschen in der eigenen Hand.
Rostock habe ich jetzt schon rausgerechnet, ehrlich gesagt.
Ich glaube, die haben auch so eine Mentalität, die können das. Die Frage ist, holt Bielefeld diese zwei Punkte auf Nürnberg auf mit dem besseren Torverhältnis? Ich glaube es nicht. Ich glaube, Nürnberg holt irgendwie die zwei Punkte, die sie brauchen, und mehr, und können diesen Vorsprung halten vor Bielefeld, weil ich bei Bielefeld in dieser Saison des Öfteren gedacht habe, jetzt haben sie es, jetzt haben sie die Kurve bekommen, und dann ging es wieder steil bergab, und da muss auch irgendetwas kaputtgegangen sein, was irgendwie irreparabel scheint in dieser Saison. Das ist so gespickt mit tollen Spielern, und es funktioniert nicht. Deswegen glaube ich, dass Bielefeld in ihre Legation muss.
Schwierig, schwierig. Bielefeld oder Nürnberg? Zwei Clubs, die darfst du eigentlich nicht sehen auf diesem Platz. Ich glaube es ähnlich wie Nando. Ich glaube, Nürnberg holt noch. Ich muss jetzt nichts mehr holen. Aber ich sehe seit mal nicht, dass Bielefeld noch viel holt. Da wirkt einfach wirklich etwas kaputt. Keine Ahnung. Letztes Jahr noch Bundesliga, und jetzt auf einmal das. Das ist schon überraschend. Das tut dann, so was der Fäne auch immer nicht. Was ist denn da los? Also keine Ahnung. Und ich dachte lange Zeit, die werden sich noch irgendwie raus retten, wie man es oft bei solchen Teams denkt. Aber nein, die stehen da unten drin. Und ich glaube, die müssen wirklich in ihre Integration. Was natürlich auch immer schwierig ist, weil die Leistungsdichte ist ja doch noch ziemlich niedrig zur 3. Liga. Und dann kommen die aus der 3. Liga mit einem Schwung. Und dann wird halt das auch brutal schwierig. Die müssen echt schauen, dass sie da nicht nochmal rutschen. Weil das wäre wahrscheinlich für den Verein schon ein harter Schlag.
Und Braunschweig rechnet ihr beide schon raus mit ihren 36 Punkten. Sind ja rein theoretisch auch nur 3 Punkte vom Relegationsplatz weg.
Ja, also Braunschweig glaube ich einfach. Die wirken so. Die haben diese Aufsteigermentalität. Die werden jetzt kämpfen bis zum Ende, glaube ich. Die haben ja sogar einen Fangesang dazu. Und ich glaube einfach, die hat mit auch mit Fera einen unglaublichen Spieler. Also von ihm halte ich unglaublich viel ein. Muss ich noch ergänzen. Und ich glaube einfach, die paar uns einfach.
Die spielen ja jetzt auch als nächstes gegen den Jagen. Sorry.
Ja, das sind dann die 3 Punkte zum Gassen.
Genau, genau. Ich muss sagen, ich bin natürlich der mit am weitesten wenigsten Ahnung hier in der Runde. Ich wurde und gleichzeitig wurde ich sozialisiert mit der Club Sadeb. Ich komme ja genau aus der Region, wo alle Clubfans sind. Das schreit alles so dermaßen danach, dass Bielefeld das Derby gewinnt und Nürnberg gegen Rostock maximalen Punkt holt. Und dann stehen die beide bei 36 oder vielleicht sogar der Club bei 35. Und dann zittern die beide aber so dermaßen in Paderborn und in Magdeburg am 34. Spieltag. Und dann macht es das Team, das einfach mehr Glück hat, so wie es halt dann ist. Mich hat positiver überrascht in dieser Saison häufiger Bielefeld. Ich habe Bielefeld schon häufiger weggesehen. Und sie haben es aber dann immer mal wieder geschafft. War das nicht in Regensburg auch so, wo dann auch Kloss getroffen hat? Ja, genau.
Kloss hat dann kurz vor Schluss an den Ballen in der Ecke geköpft. Das war auch so ein Schlag für uns. Das hat auch richtig wehgetan. Ich dachte eigentlich, das verleiht ihnen einen richtigen Aufschwung. Ich glaube, Darmstadt haben sie auch geschlagen. Und du denkst, das muss doch der Mannschaft den Job geben. Aber nein, nicht.
Das ist auch mein Problem mit Bielefeld tatsächlich aktuell.
Ja, aber andererseits. Sie haben das schon mal geschafft. Ich habe vorher noch mit Eva über ihre Auswärtsbilanz gesprochen, der Arminia. Man liegt mit 0 zu 1 in der zweiten Minute zurück. Und dann Ausgleich in der 14. Minute, in der 85. Minute, 1 zu 2 aus Sicht der Regensburger und dann in der 91. 1 zu 3. Und dann war es das. Deswegen sehe ich Nürnberg eher in noch größerer Gefahr als Bielefeld. Letztlich kann es keiner von uns wissen. Das ist wie Vuskovic, nur auf einer anderen Ebene. Ja, ihr zwei, ich danke euch sehr für diese Einblicke in eure Vereine. Das waren zwei sehr unterschiedliche Segmente. Und doch irgendwie gab es so viele Parallelen, dass ich mir aus beiden Vereinssicht ein bisschen Sorgen machen würde. Also ich hatte zwischendurch auch das Gefühl, Nando, ich weiß nicht, ob ich da jetzt zu negativ gebiased bin aus den letzten Jahren, aber ich habe auch so das Gefühl, der sportliche Erfolg ist gerade das, was beim HSV den Deckel auf dem Kochtopf hält und drunter brodelt eigentlich schon wieder die ganze Zeit. Aber wir reden halt nicht drüber.
Man weiß halt nicht, was passiert, wenn. Also was passiert nach der Saison, wenn man das Saisonziel nicht erreicht. Das ist ja eine offene Diskussion und die Strömungen im Verein. Man kann es sehr schwer einschätzen, ob dann erneut Gegenwind kommt, ob dann tatsächlich auch nicht nur Tim Walther, sondern auch Jonas Beutzig eben dem verfehlten Saisonziel stellen müssen, das Konsequenzen haben kann, was vielleicht sogar auch gerechtfertigt wäre. Diese offene Diskussion muss es ja am Ende der Saison geben, ob Aufstieg oder eben nicht. Musst du dich ja für die nächste Saison neu aufstellen oder das Ganze auch so analysieren, dass du eben noch konstanterer wirst. Wenn du aufsteigst, hast du ganz andere Anforderungen. Aber eben in der 2. Liga irgendwann kannst du solche Spieler einfach auf Dauer nicht bezahlen. Irgendwann kannst du nicht mehr so viel Transferlös generieren, dass du gute Spieler auch mit einem vernünftigen Gehalt bezahlen kannst. Das sind alles Sachen. Natürlich, je nach Saisonergebnis kann das auch in Hamburg nochmal zu medial begleitetem und natürlich auch emotionaler Fan-Begleitung zu großen Themen kommen. Wir wissen alle, in Hamburg spricht man auch gerne mit den Medien, auch wenn man es nicht sollte an der einen oder anderen Stelle. Dann kann genau das passieren, was du sagst.
Dann geht es wieder genauso weiter wie immer. Ich muss sagen, das ist jetzt ganz subjektiv und das ist überhaupt nichts gegen die anderen Vereine. Aber ich habe so krass Bock, wieder mit dem HSV, über den HSV in der Schlusskonferenz zu reden. Wahrscheinlich bereue ich es schon an Spieltag 3, wo ich dann irgendwie wieder böse Tweets bekomme, weil ich einen Witz zu viel gemacht habe. Dafür entschuldige ich mich jetzt schon. Aber es ist einfach wieder Zeit. Der HSV ist Teil des Rasenfunks, so wie Darmstadt ehrlicherweise auch. Die waren ja auch schon in der 1. Liga, als wir hier waren. Also irgendwie, ja, also... Das hätte man dem HSV doch mal sagen müssen, dass sie in die Schlusskonferenz kommen. Mensch, wahrscheinlich wird es dann... Herr Walther, wie haben Sie es geschafft, am 34. Spieltag die Mannschaft zu motivieren? Und dann hatte er halt einfach nur das hier eingespielt. Und dann wussten sie, okay, wir haben so richtig Bock. Wie schön noch, dass ich das Autor anstelle des Intros eingespielt habe. Aber dem Walther wusste er einfach nicht so genau, was er da tun soll. Aber für das Outro muss ich mich ja erst noch ordentlich von euch verabschieden. Ganz herzlichen Dank an Nando Silva, der Ed F. Santos Silva auf Twitter vom Volkspark geflüstert. Sehr empfehlenswerter HSV-Podcast. Auf Twitter auch unterwegs als HSV-Podcast. Erst schon mal gut diesen Händel bekommen zu haben. Ist es der Unterstrich, der ist richtig, ne? Genau. Also, vielen Dank, Nando, dass du hier mit dabei warst. Ich freue mich auf die Erstligaschlusskonferenzen mit dir.
Ja, vielen lieben Dank für die Einloggen. Ganz groß, war richtig toll hier. Und vor allen Dingen mit Max war das großartig. Also mit dem jungen Max. Aber absolut. Solche Eindrücke zu bekommen, grandios.
Aber echt, ey, mit 16 Jahren kann der hier im Podcast einfach, ist in der Mixed Zone und analysiert das alles durch. Und so, ich hab mit, also ich war mit 16 froh, wenn ich meine Hose richtig rumanröte. Naja, also, Max Aichinger von der Jahnblog.de. Ich werde natürlich alles verlinken. Danke dir, lieber Max, dass du hier warst. Ja, bis zum nächsten Mal. Ich drücke den Vereinen von euch beiden alle Daumen und bedanke mich bei euch auch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörern. Jetzt hören wir nochmal das Outro. Aber jetzt ist es auch wirklich so. Jetzt muss ich euch Tschüss sagen, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Das war Rasenfunk Kurzpass Nummer 265. Bleibt uns gewogen. Es gibt genügend Themen. Es gibt genügend Dinge, die man im Rasenfunk hören kann. Geht einfach mal auf rasenfunk.de, da erfahrt ihr das. Und übrigens der Rasenfunk Royale. Da gibt's jetzt auch die Threads schon im Forum unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de. Ist ja vielleicht auch für euch interessant. Macht's gut, bis bald, hier wieder im Rasenfunk.